hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
retrograde analysis problem I'd like to
share with you
the response to the first one I put out
there a couple weeks ago was
overwhelmingly positive I figured I'd
throw another your way I've been
enjoying these
this one is largely inspired by a
philosopher a concert pianist
a magician
a logician
a mathematician
I'm speaking of one person
the late Raymond Merrell smullian a man
who wore many hats throughout his life
I'm calling this one the spark
what do we want to know well who killed
the queen was it Colonel Mustard in the
library with the candlestick
all right with these retrograde analysis
problems I can't help but be reminded of
the classic board game Clue
on a more serious note what do we want
to know with this problem who captured
the White Queen and on what Square
if you'd like to try and solve this one
on your own right about now would be a
good time to pause the video and when
you return I'll be sharing some words
along with the solution of course
okay so let's make some observations
four pieces were captured
White Queen light Square Bishop White
Knight
and black Rook
we're not quite sure on what squares
exactly but that's something we can say
right away
before looking into where exactly that
White Queen was captured we may want to
ask where was the black Rook captured
and who captured it
was it captured on one of these four
squares how else could it get out was a
white knight capturing The Rook no
this guy right here is a big tell
made a capture to get to F3
and there's only one black piece that
was captured so the black Rook was
captured on F3
how did it get there
well a file must have opened
how did the file open well let's see how
that may have happened
starting from the original position
the White Knight comes out and
hops into G6
this is providing a necessary spark for
future events
Now The Rook is deployed along the H
file
then it gets to F3 and is captured and
this now releases
the light Square bishop and queen
they could now sneak out the king gets
out of the way
and well hang on for a moment we have
two remaining captures on H6 and B6 do
you see a problem
they're both dark squares
and a light Square Bishop cannot be
captured on B6 or H6
we have reached a dead end what does
this mean it means the White Knight must
have been captured elsewhere
let's go back
the White Knight was in fact captured on
H6
and the black Rook was deployed along
the G file to get to F3
captured and now the bishop and queen
are released and the big difference here
is that the remaining
captures
one light and one dark we can satisfy
those conditions
we can position the pieces
like so
and in the end the bishop is captured on
G6
who captured
the White Queen
it was the Black Sea Pawn
on B6
how'd you do with this one
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video I've been having fun with
these retrograde analysis problems feel
free to leave a comment let me know how
you did with this one
that's all for now take care bye